this is Jocko podcast number 155 with me
Jocko Willington on the island the dead
were piling up in the mission report the
head of the convoy wrote at 2:00 p.m. on
May 20th I went to the island of nezzie
know with commander cap scoff there was
a terrible scramble people crowding and
fighting around the bags of flour dead
bodies everywhere a hundred or more and
lots of people crawling about and crying
give us bread boss it's been two days
since we've been given anything to eat
they're trying to make us die of hunger
and the cold they told us that people
had begun eating the dead bodies that
they were cooking human flesh the scene
on the island was dreadful appalling on
May 21st alone the three health officers
counted 70 additional dead bodies in
five cases they emphasized the liver the
heart the lungs and fleshy part of
bodies had been cut off on one of the
bodies the head had been torn off along
the along with the male genital organs
and part of the skin these mutilations
constitute strong evidence of
cannibalistic acts in addition they
suggest the existence of serious
psychopathologies on the same day May
21st the deportees themselves brought us
three individuals who had been caught
with blood on their hands and holding
human livers
our examination of these three
individuals did not reveal any extreme
emaciation and there's an elderly local
peasant woman who reported the things we
saw people were dying everywhere they
were killing each other there was a
guard named Costilla viniq off a young
fellow he was courting a pretty girl who
had been sent there he protected her one
day he had to be away for a while
and he told one of his comrades take
care of her but with all the people the
comrade couldn't do much people caught
the girl tied her to a tree caught off
her breasts her muscles everything they
could eat they were hungry they had to
eat when costia came back she was still
alive he tried to save her but she had
lost too much blood she died that was
the kind of thing that happened when you
went along the island you saw flesh
wrapped in rags human flesh that had
been cut and hung in the trees
and that right there is from a book
called cannibal Island by Nicolas Werth
who's written books about communism I
think his most famous is the black book
of communism and cannibal Island
specifically breaks down one of the
small individual nightmares of the
Soviet gulags but the nightmare was not
small and it certainly was not specific
it was a widespread and it was broad and
it was almost incomprehensible and very
little about it would be known or not
for one man Alexander Solzhenitsyn who
not only survived the gulags but lived
on to write incredibly detailed and very
well researched two books about the
gulags some of them were fictionalized
like a day in the life of Ivan
Denisovich and for the for the good of
the cause but most comprehensively in
his three-volume tome The Gulag
Archipelago and this series is is a
massive series and it's been cut down to
an abridged version that was actually
approved by the author himself and the
abridged version has just been
re-released in Europe with a foreword by
a man that I think repopulated a to
discuss that book and among other things
I'm sure a man that I needed to give an
introduction to the first time he was on
this podcast but now who needs no
introduction whatsoever a man by the
name of dr. Jordan B Peterson Jordan
thank you for coming back on how does it
rough beginning chuckle Jesus yeah
I remember when I started listening to
you you would say something along the
lines of that you know we are quite
capable of creating hell for ourselves
as human beings and that clearly that
situation I don't know I mean that's
that's that's hell yeah and close enough
yeah and it's it's it's created by us
it's created by us which i think is
obviously horrific and the Gulag
Archipelago you know you talked about
that book a lot and and one of the
things that on that book hits you hard
obviously for me there's a book called
about face by by colonel david hackworth
I'm from a different world I guess that
you in many ways
the book that hit me hardest in my life
was was that book about face and it's
it's one of those things that when I
read it I started putting it together as
like things started to fit and I
remember that and I was wondering I
guess from my perspective at what point
did you read the Gulag Archipelago and
at what point did you start to say okay
there's something really really
important here for me to try and
understand well I read it back in the
1980s early I would say I'd read some
Solzhenitsyn before that I read the ley
de Dave day in the life of Ivan
Denisovich when I was about 13 or 14 and
then I read the Gulag Archipelago in my
early 20s when I was reading a lot of
psychological material too when I
started reading Jung and Freud and the
great clinicians and I was reading a
fair bit about what had happened in Nazi
Germany at the same time and also Victor
Frankel's met man's search for meaning
and
Solzhenitsyn's book is in some ways like
an elaborated extension of Frankle
Frankle of course described what
happened to him in the Nazi
concentration camps and it's a
relatively short book and it's a great
book but Solzhenitsyn's book is it's
it's much broader and and I would say
deeper and the thing that affected me
most particularly was the psychological
take on the on the totalitarian states
you know I had been studying political
science up to that point and the
political science scientists and the
economists who I would say were under
the sway of Marxist thinking although
not nearly to the degree that they are
now were convinced that the reason that
people engaged in conflict was basically
a consequence of argumentation over
resources you know it's basically an
economic argument and I never bought
that it never made sense to me I mean
obviously there are circumstances where
that's true but it didn't seem to be
fundamentally the case like tribal
warfare isn't precisely about resources
it's maybe it's about territory or maybe
it's about identity but it never seemed
to me to be simply about resources
partly because well a resource is
something that people value but it isn't
obvious why people value what they value
and so it doesn't solve the fundamental
problem anyways when I was reading
Frankel and Solzhenitsyn I started to
more deeply understand the relationship
between the individual and the atrocity
and that's what I found most interesting
was that Frankel's claim and
Solzhenitsyn's claim as well that it was
the moral corruption of the citizenry
that allowed the totalitarian
catastrophes to occur and that that in
some sense was the responsibility of
every individual in the system who
looked the other way or who participated
actively I mean even in the gulag camps
themselves they were almost all run by
the prisoners there wasn't enough
administrative manpower to run the
prison system without the cooperation so
to speak
the prisoners so it is it is a surreal
sort of hell where you imprison yourself
and Solzhenitsyn's fundamental claim and
this was true for Frankel as well and
also for vaclav havel
who eventually became president of
Czechoslovakia or at least of the Czech
Republic I don't remember which you know
they believed that it was the individual
proclivity to accept lies that fostered
the ability of tyrants to destroy the
state and then well and that also led to
complicitous with regards to all the
absolute atrocities that were occurring
in both the Nazi state in the and in the
Soviet state and I think that's true
when I read like I read Solzhenitsyn's
books and a lot of the books I read
about Nazi Germany - not as a victim and
not as a hero but as a perpetrator you
know which I think it's really important
it's something that's really important
to do when you read history is that it's
easy to cast yourself as a victim it's
easy to cast yourself as the person who
would have been heroic in the
circumstance but it's also unbelievably
useful to understand that there's a good
chance had you been in those situations
that you wouldn't have been on the side
of the good guys you know and that's a
terrible it's really a terrible
realization but it's it's necessary
realization again just going back to
this idea of what you get out of reading
because people ask me how cuz I read
books all the time on my podcast and
what you just said it struck me as
something that's people have told me I
read that book before but I didn't
really get out of it what you got out of
it and when I heard you read it I said I
was saying wow how did I need to go
reread this book and I think one of the
key things is you looked at these books
as you were not the victim but the
perpetrator one thing that when I read
books I know I read a lot of books
mostly about war for me I always think
about the the peep I don't know we see
myself as the person that goes and
heroically storms the beaches
and survives every you know in a war
book there's these people that get
mentioned for a for up for a half a
paragraph or for two sentences and they
sometimes they don't even have a name
because you know you're the battalion
commander storming the beach at Normandy
you don't you you're not gonna name
every single person but for some reason
and maybe it's just my experiences of
being in combat when I read about that
two sentences of that guy that that gets
shot that gets killed that gets blown up
I completely understand and relate to
that person like I don't just see it as
me being the guy that is always winning
and always doing okay and always
surviving I feel and relate to those
guys that didn't and and part of that is
just because of my friends that I lost
in combat like those guys that they're
they're people and and I think that key
thing of of reading it and going man
every single person like when you read
about these girl you're talking about
millions of people that were tortured
died murdered every one of those people
key word is people every one of those
people is a person and to your point
every single one of those executioner's
every single one of those murderers is
also a person you know there's a great
book called ordinary men oh yeah we we
reviewed that on this podcast right
right and so you know it's it's it's one
of the greatest books written about what
happened in the Second World War I think
on the end of on the atrocity end
because the author does such a lovely
job of while it's a strange way of
putting it in this context but you know
it's about this police battalion that
was moved into Poland after the Germans
went through and and occupied the
country and they were there to establish
order like police do but also to
participate in the mopping up let's say
that was part and parcel of the war and
you know these were ordinary policemen
middle-class guys most of whom had been
educated and socialized before the Nazi
propaganda machine really got rolling
they weren't like Hitler Youth types
mm-hmm they were ordinary men and they
were brought and they had a commander
who had made an explicit case that if
they weren't able to tolerate the
conditions in Poland that they could go
home so there was no top-down order that
you had to do this or else and then they
were you know first of all they started
rounding up while mostly Jewish people
men between 18 and 65 and then you know
they started to participate in the
entire atrocious mess and they were they
ended up many of them taking naked
pregnant women out into fields and
shooting them in the back of the head
and what the author does is outline how
that happens to you you know one step at
a time and so it's a really horrifying
book and it's a brilliant book because
there's no attempt to make the
perpetrators like some creatures that
aren't human like just pure Psychopaths
and of course in in a situation like
Nazi Germany and and in the horrors of
the communist States there was no
shortage of places for Psychopaths to
prevail but that's not really the issue
the issue is well how does an ordinary
person come to participate in a global
horror let's say and what does that mean
about being an ordinary person and then
the next question is well what does it
mean about how you should conduct your
life and one of the things that I mean I
think what happened to me when I read
all this material in the 80s was that I
became convinced that there wasn't
anything more important to do in the
aftermath of what had happened in the
20th century then to try to build people
who were responsible enough as
truth-telling courageous responsible
citizens so that the probability would
increase that if they were in a position
to make a terrible choice that they
would make the right one and I would say
this lecture tour that I'm doing which
is now extended over more than a hundred
cities is an extension of the same thing
well I think it's the same thing that
you're trying to do with your book like
we were just looking at
my key in the Dragons book right and
you're trying to lay out a psychological
pathway that guides people towards
responsibility and courage and truth and
all of that and that is the bulwark
against tyranny and it's actually the in
debts actually at the individual level
and we kind of know that like we we know
that in the West I think that's part of
the core ethos of well certainly the of
the English common law system certainly
of the American way of looking at the
world is that each citizen is the
bulwark against tyranny and that's
actually true it's and and that's a
terrible thing to think through because
it means that you are responsible for
the integrity or lack thereof of your
state and it's it's on you you know and
and there's something great about that
because it means that your existence
actually matters to you and to your
family and and to the broader community
in a really major way in a way that's
much more significant than you might
think and that the your proclivity to
abdicate your moral responsibility
Echo's way farther than you might
consider especially under some
circumstances you know in Solzhenitsyn
one of the things that's so amazing
about the Gulag Archipelago is his
stories not only of the absolute bloody
catastrophe of the Soviet state and his
incredibly astute documentation of the
role that the utopian political and
philosophical assumptions of Marxism
played in creating the system right it
wasn't an aberration
it was a direct logical consequence of
that collectivist viewpoint and to
document all that but also to tell
endless stories about people who were
able at least to some degree to not
become corrupted even under unbelievably
horrific conditions you know and that's
something you also get out of Victor
Frankel's book man's search for meaning
you know on it and so the the Gulag
Archipelago is a story about horror in
some sense but it's more a story of the
triumph
the fundamental triumph of the human
spirit and perhaps no more perhaps most
evident in the case of Solzhenitsyn
himself because he memorized this book
in some sense while he was in the camps
and then wrote it under extreme duress
afterwards and it's an immense
undertaking and it's unbelievably
emotionally intense the entire book it's
like one
you know seventeen hundred page scream
of outrage did he just can hardly
believe that someone can write at that
white-hot intensity for such a long
period of time and you know his book had
an unbelievable global impact I think it
sold 30 million copies and it definitely
for at least a reasonable period of time
made it completely untenable for utopian
resentful utopian intellectuals to
ethically justify their radical leftist
collectivism it just blew the slats out
from underneath any ethical credibility
that communism that that remained of the
Communist doctrine by the 1970s and that
that's a hell of a thing for someone to
manage on their own it's a pretty big
task so while you were going through
that I was thinking myself so I was
talking to I still talk to military
folks and I was talking to some military
leaders the young leader so like platoon
level and company level leaders so these
are guys that are in charge of you know
40 guys or maybe 150 guys and and you
know you can have some real ethical
problems and and one of the things that
I said to this group was I said hey in
your in your platoon you've got a
murderer in your platoon you've got
someone in your platoon that as a sadist
and they were kind of looking at me
suspect you know a little bit like oh
come on now
come on what are you talking about how
big is the platoon a platoon is forty
guys oh yeah yeah and he's got someone
in there like that and I was I was
actually gonna ask you how accurate I
was and then I was gonna actually say
that no matter
what you say how accurate is even if it
was even if it wasn't one out of every
thousand you have to act as a leader as
if in your platoon you've got one of
those guys that's the way you need to
well you look and there's another book
mmm called The Rape of Nanking we've
covered that yeah well so one of the
things that was really horrifying about
that book is so imagine that there's
maybe let's say that there's one in a
hundred just for the sake of argument
that's really got cruel and psychopathic
traits what do you think professionally
what do you think that number is oh I
think 1% isn't unreasonable it could be
higher than that I mean it there's
gradations right right yeah there's
probably a group of 40 people there's
gonna be one guy in there whose
proclivity in that direction is
sufficiently strong so that you better
keep an eye on them that's for sure and
this is a group of people that joined
the military right so they're already
you know you've already gotten you've
already got a group that's ok with with
theoretically having to kill other
people right so this is probably you
know so if it's 100 that's likely an
underestimate so I think your estimate
is perfectly reasonable and it might be
conservative what happened in Nanking
was that the most sadistic people became
the targets of imitation and emulation
and that's when things really get out of
hand
yeah right so and that's the same thing
with Emil I massacre and and that was so
when I was talking this group and I'm
getting and I said to him I said you're
looking at me like right now like I'm
like I don't know what I'm talking about
like I'm crazy mmm who knows about the
meal I mascar and and you know all of a
sudden it got quiet because if you know
anything about the meal I'm asked her it
was a normal group of guys it was a
normal group of guys there's a normal
company of American soldiers and you
know what they've been through some
stress mmm they've been through you know
they'd had their friends killed and it
was in Vietnam there was no one really
to react against or to take your
aggression out on because the enemy you
couldn't see him they would hide and it
was but then they turned and they
snapped and the same thing you had the
leader a guy named lieutenant Calley who
was the platoon leader who I'd love for
you to do a psychological profile maybe
you he's one of these guys it was kind
of like it was it totally insecure about
everything right and so he got those
shoulder boards on which is the way
the way sultanate yeah right right his
his experience beautiful tune leader
yeah and what it did to him and he goes
through that this boy fantastic to hear
when he talks about what he did he know
he was looking back saying oh I did this
and I didn't listen to this little
rampage of things that he how he acted
as a commander yeah I ate the food the
good food right in front of my guys when
they weren't good in for I was getting
the good food and he took advantage of
all the little all the little comforts
that you got being in an officer yeah
well what yeah well he was trying in the
in the whole book and especially in that
section which i think is in vol ii which
i think is the greatest of the three
volumes especially the last half of it
which is just absolutely it's it's
genius level right income unbelievably
compelling and brilliant and yeah i mean
he he said that when he was in the camps
that one of the things that he did
especially once he started to identify
people that he truly admired was to go
over his life with a fine-tooth comb and
try to try to remember everything that
he did wrong by his own estimation and
then try to set it right in some manner
and so there was a that's a repentance
and then a redemption right there's
there's a real there's a real
fundamental like a medieval christian
undertone to all of that but it what one
of the things that's quite interesting
is that when you talk about issues that
are this serious you're almost
inevitably in a situation where you're
going to find yourself compelled to use
some kind of quasi religious language
because you end up discussing good and
evil and issues of redemption and issues
of repentance and issues of conscience
and and sin and all of that there isn't
language that's deep enough to get at it
otherwise and what Solzhenitsyn did was
scour his conscience and try to put
himself together partly because he was
shamed he was ashamed of himself in the
face of these extraordinarily
extraordinary people who seemed to be
able to keep their moral compass under
circumstances where no one should ever
assume that they would keep their moral
compass because certainly like I said
when I was reading this the Gulag and
other books like that I never assumed
that if I was in those situations that I
would have been one of the people who
kept
their head and we're able to withstand
the temptation to become a trustee for
example and to take things the easy way
and to lord it over the other prisoners
and to and to adopt that position of
authority you know it's like it's like a
head slave among slaves but you know you
could say well better to be the head
slave than to be the bottom slave and
well that's true in some sense with
regards to creature comfort but as
Solzhenitsyn point out points out it
might be a little bit hard on your soul
and that actually turns out to be
something of crucial not only crucial
importance psychologically but crucial
importance sociologically and
politically because if you sacrifice
that then you warp the structure around
you which is exactly what happened in in
the establishment of these camps you
know in the the soviet union was just
one big lie what was their old joke they
pretend to pay us and we pretend to work
it's like the whole the whole book and
the whole soviet union when you when you
read about it now it seems like it's it
it seems like a bad joy it seems like a
bad movie you couldn't move with just
the way the way that stalin would do
something and in the way that that order
were coming out it seems like one of
those cheesy um you know comedic movies
about these decisions that they're
making and yeah it's surreal it's it's
completely it's completely insane you
know at one point he's talking about the
there was a new penalty for when they
call it clipping corn or or yeah they're
basically a twelve-year-old kid would be
starving
and go into a field yeah and clip a cure
of a corn an ear of corn yeah that
happened in the Ukraine during the
decolonization right it was against the
law to go out after the fields were were
harvested it was against the law to go
out and pick grain off the ground to
feed your family right and the prison
sentence was like a tenner which is
there a little word for ten years so
you're gonna get you you steal a piece
of corn or you pick up corn off the
ground and you're getting ten years yeah
you can't comprehend that that is very
hard to machine that yeah work yeah and
they were they you know he'd in the
earlier parts of the book when he start
going through the trials that they were
doing on people yeah it's completely
crazy I can grind Kalka yeah well that's
why I hate to see the kangaroo courts
emerging all over all over the West you
know and and and with the university
sort of at the forefront of that so
we're building these alternative court
systems constantly that don't follow
standard legal procedure and it's really
I mean we're messing with things that
that we shouldn't be messing with and
yeah the whole that I mean there are
there are accounts I believe it's in the
gulag of applause after ass tell in a
speech right where people would stand up
and applaud and and they and they'd
applaud until until literally the old
people were falling over because if you
were the first person to stop applauding
then you were well it was off to the
camps with you know he absolutely
outlines it so that's that sounds so
crazy to say and he outlines a specific
thing that happened it's that right
there these no one will stop applauding
him because they're afraid they're gonna
get ratted out you know I there but by
everyone else
yeah well been manned by the people who
are in fact watching and I mean you know
what by the end by the by the collapse
of East Germany one third of the people
were in for informers for the state and
so if you had a family of six people
two of your family members were direct
government informers you know and it's
it's so it's it's creepy in some sense
and it's a very weak word to use in this
situation but okay when I was at New
York University talking to Jonathan
hight about I don't know it was about a
few months ago he just wrote that book
called the coddling of the American mind
you know and he took me into one of the
men's washrooms there and there's a
poster on the wall asking students to
turn each other in
for instances of bias or offensive
speech and they have a whole bureaucracy
that's designed to do nothing else but
adjudicate these instances of biased
speech and these posters are up on the
walls as if this is something to be
proud of you know and the same thing is
happening now in Scotland where the
Scottish police are doing exactly the
same thing they're asking citizens to
turn each other in for for hate crimes
you know and
the problem with that is the fundamental
problem with that and the the unsolvable
problem is well who defines hate and and
and where's where's the line drawn it's
like well anything that upsets me that
you say is hate that and then it's worse
than that it's like what happens is the
people who define hate end up being
those who are looking to take offense so
that they can find someone they can
define as a victimizer so that they can
persecute them morally and justify that
inner sadism and those are the people
who end up defining the laws and then
they mask this with the morality saying
while we're doing this to make our
society a safe place it's absolutely
it's it's absolutely dreadful and to see
that happening in the UK was just it's
just awful because I mean you know the
UK is a centre Assent the center point
of the idea of free speech I mean a lot
of America obviously a lot of American
ideals America is a great center of free
speech but I mean it's a variation on
the English system so to see that
happening in the UK is just it's awful
and to see the police doing this and
being you know encouraged by the
politicians and and and and to see this
put forward as some sort of moral action
it's just well it's it's an echo of this
kind of catastrophe that that we're
discussing so I think about that
sometimes and I also have a tendency to
look at things and let not be too
worried about it like hey come on
yeah what's really good yeah right and
that's yeah that's actually part of my
personality and part of that comes from
my old job where hey I can't worry about
these little things oh there's some
little problem going over there that's
that's not gonna be that's not gonna
fact us it's not gonna and you got to
pay attention a little bit make sure it
doesn't get out of hand but that thing
about speech and and you just mentioned
the the kulak that sorry still lacks
yeah yeah they were the Ukrainian they
were the Ukrainian farmers who were good
at farming when I read this part it got
me worried about my own personal laksa
days ago attitude towards things that I
think all that's not a big deal let me
let me read this little section about
the
about the escalation of the word kulak
yeah and and where it started and we're
dead yeah that's good so here we go
in Russian a Kulak is a miserly
dishonest rural trader who grows rich
not by his own labour but through
someone else's in every locality even
before the Revolution such cruel acts
could be numbered on one's fingers and
the revolution totally destroyed their
basis of activity subsequently after
1917 by a transfer of meaning the name
kulak began to be applied to all those
who in any way hired workers even if it
was owned Eve even if it was only when
they were temporarily short of working
hands in their own families but and that
doesn't stop there the inflation of this
scathingly term of this scathing term
cuckoo lock proceeded relentlessly and
by 1930 all strong peasants in general
who were being so-called
all peasants strong and management
strong in work or even strong merely in
convictions the term Kulak was used to
smash the strength of the peasantry and
I gotta I gotta go a little bit further
because hell of a thing for the Workers
Party to do ain't crazy yeah they went
further though beyond this in every
village there were people who in one way
or another had personally gotten in the
way of the local activists this was the
perfect time to settle accounts with
them of jealousy envy and insult these
are the people you were just talking
about a new word was needed for these
new victims as a class and it was born
by this time it had no social or
economic content whatsoever but it had a
marvelous sound pod kulaks Nick and that
meant a person aiding the kulaks
in other words I consider you an
accomplice of the enemy
yeah and that's all it took yeah well
one of the things I tried to outline in
my forward to the abridged version was I
was thinking about this idea of oddly
enough about intersectionality which is
uh like social justice idea you know
that the social justice idea is that
we're best defined by our collective
identity and that the proper narrative
in relationship to our collective
identity is one of victim victimizer
which is a replay of the old Marxist
doctrine of bourgeois z and proletariat
it's just in its new guys I mean and
that new guys developed at least in part
in response to the Gulag Archipelago
because the old proletariat bourgeoisie
distinction became morally untenable so
it just went underground and underwent
this transformation the intersectional
theorists point out that your status as
a victimizer or a victim is actually the
intersection of your multiple identities
and so and that's actually the Achilles
heel of the collectivist notion and we
can get into why that is but there's a
horror that goes along with that that
people that's that's not obvious that I
think contributed to exactly why the
Russian Revolution went so horribly
wrong and that is that so imagine that I
could characterize you along five or six
different dimensions of group identity
it's pretty easy and while your mail
your mail of a certain age your mail of
a certain age and economic class your
you have a certain sexual orientation
you have a certain ethnicity you have a
certain race that's six groups right
there and we could continue you know
your parents had a certain
socio-economic class and so did your
grandparents and and then your ethnic
group had a certain privilege or lack
thereof and you're attractive or you're
not attractive and you're intelligent or
you're not intelligent and there's
templeman temperamental variability like
there's all sorts of ways of
characterizing you according to your
group okay now we might say that if we
were compassionate people that we would
take one of those group identities or
more and look at where your dispossessed
and victimized okay and we're gonna find
some dimension along which you're less
privileged than some people like maybe
you come from a working-class background
despite the fact that you're like a
straight male and so you can be a victim
on that
dimension and so and that's kind of
that's at least in part an element of
intersectional theory right and that may
be your your your oppression is the
product of your multiple victim like
identities but that can easily be
reversed because it's absolutely the
case that I can take any person and I
can do add multi-dimensional analysis of
their group identities and I can find at
least one dimension along which they're
the perpetrator not the victim
they're the victimizer not the victim
and as soon as I can identify a
dimension along which they're a
victimizer then that justifies their
persecution and so one of the things
that you saw happening in the Russian
Revolution and it's very much akin to
what you just described was that the the
borders of who who was validly accused
of being a victimizer essentially
expanded to include everyone and and
that's actually right in it's it's in a
perverse sense it's right because if you
position yourself properly in in the
historical flow then you should see
yourself as a perpetrator and a victim
equally well it's not the right way to
see yourself at all but if you're gonna
play that game you're gonna be on both
sides of it and then that issue is and
this is related to your idea about you
know in your platoon you've got one
person who's sadistic it's like okay
well let's even assume that at the
beginning of the Russian Revolution that
the vast majority of the people who were
motivated by communism were actually
compassionate with regards to the
dispossessed peasantry now I don't
believe that but we could say that that
was even a significant minority well the
question is did you just say on it
mmm-hmm what was your what was your
hypothetical percentage well well let's
say well let's say it's 20% or let's
even say it's 50% of people who are
genuinely motivated by compassion for
the dispossessed but then there's
another minority maybe we could even say
it was only 10% to begin with who
weren't motivated by that at all they
were motivated by the jealousy and the
spite and the and and the resentment
that Solzhenitsyn describes and they
were the ones who were after those to be
persecuted
the thing is they got the upper-hand
really rapidly and it might be because
the carnivorous types the predatory
types are much more dangerous and
powerful than the compassionate types
like they'll take them out instantly
we're we're willing to step up and smash
someone yes most of the people that are
saying oh we just want to help
yes exactly well and there's someone I
actually cited a guy named I think his
name was Walter Lots us in the foreword
who who wrote wrote in a journal called
Red Terror that if you were
interrogating an enemy of the state you
didn't bother with niceties like their
individual guilt that was a burrs huazi
conceit and that's that's a really
important thing to keep in mind what you
wanted to do is to do a class-based
analysis and find out well are they a
member of let's say the Kulak or the
affiliates of the kulaks which is a
lovely way of expanding your list of
potential victims and then you you
execute accordingly and that would mean
well the person that you're
interrogating right or the class member
that you're interrogating and then their
children and perhaps also their
grandchildren and latsis himself was
eventually executed by the Stellan as
somebody wrote to me after i wrote the
foreword and told me that that was his
eventual fate and I thought well talk
about standing on a chair and putting
the noose around your own neck and
kicking it out from underneath you it's
like you know he basically he murdered
himself fundamentally and and you know
you could say in some sense that was the
story of the Soviet Union to it to a
tremendous degree yeah there's one part
going back to the the ever-expanding
people that need to be destroyed there's
a point in the book where he starts he's
saying hey look there's insects Stalin's
just described or maybe was Lenin was
describing these certain people as
insects you don't need to be destroyed
and then he just that that just starts
off with hey people that are rabble
rousers yeah they're insects and and
then it just expands and expands and
it's got priests and then it's got
engineers oh yeah and physicians and
physicians everyone in wreckers yeah
records that's that's the word that they
use there that he uses in the book for
first basically saboteurs yeah and that
expands beyond comprehension yeah
because at every scene
problem that there is is the fault of
some person out there that sabotage yeah
and and they they do this show trial and
he talks about in the book for I think
that I think the phrase that he uses or
that they use at the Russian that the
Soviets used was organizers of the
famine huh meaning like oh yeah you're
starving and these people over here
they're the reason you're these are the
people that organized the famine they're
the Wreckers of production of food and
you bet you bet well it was either that
you know you imagine that you you you
adopt a worldview and that worldview
enables you to at least in principle
organize yourself with other people and
to provide you with a certain amount of
psychological stability and then things
go dreadfully wrong and then you have a
choice which is to reevaluate your
worldview which is of course what
Solzhenitsyn does in the Gulag
Archipelago in a very deep ways
reorganize his entire worldview or you
can look for reasons why you're right
and and these things are happening and
Solzhenitsyn talks a lot in the Gulag
Archipelago about see he had a moral
conundrum when he was in prison and he
started his moral awakening let's say
and he was trying to figure out how to
treat other people who were imprisoned
he had a real moral conundrum when a
committed communist was dragged into the
gulag system which happened all the time
he said those people were in
particularly dire straits because not
only had they been subject to the entire
tyrannical weight of the deceitful state
but it was at the hands of their own
comrades and friends and then the the
the committed communists would enter the
gulag and they would still be in there
morally superior phase right that that
their incarceration was a mistake and
that things would be set right and that
there was nothing wrong with the system
and they would attempt to justify it and
Solzhenitsyn was never sure how to react
to these people ethically because on the
one hand well they were you know
devastated because now there were
political prisoners and maybe they got a
20-year sentence and they were in
terrible you know stripped of their
family and just ruined but on the other
hand they were still avid supporters of
the very fist that had crushed them and
so his eventual conclusion
was that until they broke and repented
they they weren't to be allied with they
were still essentially on the side of
the wall of the perpetrator and it seems
to me that that that's right that's
that's unrepentant sin let's say and it
isn't until you what what would you say
until you take responsibility for your
own complicit 'no sin you're in your
unfair interrogation that you get to
join the ranks of of valuable and
suffering humanity again and so yeah
it's that the the extension of the
persecution is really something that's
horrifying
to see how who constituted the
victimizer
the ranks of who constituted victimizer
just grew and grew and grew or one of
the most shocking groups of people that
ended up in the gulags were the damned
soviet soldiers then it just got back oh
yeah that's the thing you can't make up
you can't make that up a giving
Solzhenitsyn who who was like in close
combat with the enemy and he wrote a
letter to one of his buddies and said
yeah this doesn't seem like to be a
great decision by Stalin yeah
and next thing you know he's he's in
yeah and prison yeah well the stellen
stellen decided that yeah this is
something that you you you can't you
can't believe this well it is there is
this like it's like you know if there's
something satanic at the bottom of this
you know mythologically speaking there's
also something that's like a cosmic it's
like cosmic black humor it's like the
the sign on auswitch that said work will
set you free
you know and that's a joke right it's a
whole it's a terrible terrible dark joke
and so much of this has the element of
of exactly that kind of surreal I hate
to say humor but it's it's right I mean
Stalin decided that the okay so the
Soviet prisoners of war were not covered
by the Geneva Convention for the
treatment of prisoners of war castellan
refused to sign that agreement so like
if you were an allied prisoner of the
Germans it wasn't like you were having a
great time
it like food was in short supply and you
were treated pretty brutally but the
Soviets were kept separately and they
were doing so badly that the Allies used
to throw food packets over the fence
when that was an option so the Soviet
prisoners of war were treated absolutely
dreadfully and and now and Stellan
didn't care about that and then when
they were released and went back to the
Soviet Union
his dictum was that because they had
been exposed to the capitalist West or
even the Nazi West for that matter that
they had now been intolerably corrupted
on ideological grounds and had to be put
in the prison camps so that was the that
was your destiny as you know I mean
first of all you were a frontline
Russian soldier which was just brutal
beyond belief their army was completely
unprepared for Hitler's invasion because
Stalin trusted Hitler in in his strange
way and so they were completely
unprepared and of course then fighting
in the Soviet Union with its winters I
mean you just you just can't imagine
what that must have been like and then
to be thrown in a prisoner of war camp
at the bottom of the rung and then to be
brought back to your country and then to
be imprisoned as a traitor because as a
class you'd been exposed to the wrong
ideology it's like you just it's it's
it's unimaginably vile and surreal at
the same time and it is shake your head
for me well it's such a shock to read
the Gulag Archipelago it you just can't
it's it's like it is it's like Dante's
Inferno it's like a trip into hell yeah
yeah and I guess your that's what I was
trying to say when we started this
conversation I was trying to say that
it's like you're watching this like like
you said it's like a bad comedy movie
and you'd think well that's that'd be
really that way you'd think you know
when you take a comedy well one of the
things one of the ways you can make
people laugh is to take something
ordinary and maybe make it much more
extreme in the more extreme you make it
the more funny it becomes that's what
like happened here you're looking at
this thing going
hey oh yeah they seem to be trying to
make this funny because who in could
ever conceive that you could take your
frontline soldiers who were
captured and in misery and when they
return home instead of treating them
like heroes
instead you put them back into a prison
the worse one even you can't even you
can't even that's just that's no no you
can't make this stuff up can't make it
up no did you see I believe that movie
was the death of Stalin did you I did
not oh yeah but that's worth seeing
because it's it's very interesting
because one of the things about that
movie is that it captures that surreal
element because it's a black comedy you
know and and there are comical things
happening in the movie in that terrible
dark way constantly at the same time
that in the background genuinely
terrible things are happening so it's
that horrible it's that it's it's got
that horrible satirical flavor that runs
through books like The Gulag Archipelago
where you think well there's just no
this is so absurd that there's no
possible way it could have occurred and
yet that's not only did it happen there
was like a contest to top the absurdity
you know to to to consider the engineers
for example Wreckers is well these
people were building the Soviet system
to the degree that it was built and then
to turn around and accuse exactly those
people of being the ones who destroy and
undermine it it's it's part of I really
think that what's what underlies this
whatever this is and I think this is
what manifests itself in the worst of
the leftist collectivism is a real
hatred for anything that smacks of
competence at all like I I tried to
imagine those Russian villages because
that come from a small town a small
northern town too so I kind of I tried
to imagine so imagine that you're in an
isolated village and it's a peasant
village and the peasants weren't freed
that long ago right they were basically
serfs until until about the the middle
of the second half of the nineteenth
century
and so they had been emancipated and
then some of those people who were
emancipated got a little bit of land and
started to have a life you know started
to be successful peasants and they were
also the people that grew the bulk of
the crops because what you see happening
in any productive domain is that a small
percentage of people do almost all the
productive work
there's a small percentage of productive
farmers who grew all the crops right and
then there's all sorts of farmers who
were only farmers by name and they
weren't successful at all so you have
and then there is a certain relationship
between being productive as a farmer and
developing some wealth they'll maybe you
had a house and maybe you could hire a
person or two you know and which you
think would be actually be a good thing
especially if you were also growing food
okay so you imagine you you get a
village and now there's a bit of a
socio-economic pyramid and there's some
people that are doing well and they're
really and they're and it isn't the
crooked people that are really annoying
though people who like the genuine cool
acts let's say that that small
percentage of psychopathic types who
were basically profiting criminally off
the efforts of others those aren't so
annoying those people because they're
rich but they don't deserve it and so
they don't stand towards you as a moral
ideal that shames you but the really
annoying people are the ones who are
doing well and deserve it especially if
you're someone who's doing nothing and
is bitter okay so now so there's the
village and you've got your people who
are doing all right and then you've got
a huge strata of people who aren't upset
about the people who are doing well they
might even admire them and be happy that
they're around because they're making
the community thrive and growing some
food then you have this little this
little strata at the bottom of people
who are near do wells and on the more
psychopathic end of things and they are
bitter and resentful and and waiting for
their bloody opportunity and then the
communist intellectuals come into town
and say you know those people that are
doing well they actually everything
they've got is ill-gotten and they they
stole it and they stole it from you from
you like and look at how badly you're
doing and the reason you're doing badly
is because these these people who are
lording it over you and who have all
this creature comfort they they took
that from you it's yours by right and so
then all that resentment and jealousy
and hatred and rage alcohol-fueled as
you might well imagine has this moral
reason to go with pitchforks and and in
a mob and surround those houses and to
strip them of everything they have and
to rape the women and to kill the
occupants or to ship them off to the
middle of Siberia when they're where
they froze to death because there were
No or died of dysentery or or whatever
other plague managed to you know weave
its way through these camps and so you
have the you have the intellectuals
providing the moral rationale for the
worst ethical actors in these small
villages doing the worst possible things
under the guise of compassion right and
that's part of that victim victimizer
narrative it's just an engineering like
you could imagine that you can imagine a
dark night you can imagine the winter
you can imagine the alcohol you can
imagine the rage that fuels these people
who are drinking too much in the pub's
that have been sitting there for the
last 20 years
like what would you say eating up their
own Souls with resentment and bitterness
and then someone comes in and says
you're the true victim here and here's
the people that you can go after and
then like if you play that on your
imagination you get some real sense of
exactly what sort of horror that would
produce you know you think about the
rape for example or or just the theft or
but but it's the rape that you can
really think about us as absolute
revenge for all that bitter resentment
all fueled by the fact that you know
you'd sat there for the last twenty
years being completely goddamn useless
and bitter and and and and angry and and
and and fantasizing about the day that
would come where you'd have your
opportunity God and then the whole
country and that was the whole country
oh it was just unbelievable yeah and I
think he spells that out very clearly
and he says it's you know what he's
saying you know I'm saying that you got
a psychopath in your platoon he's saying
that psychopath all that psychopath
needs to flip is is the is someone to
tell them that that's the right thing
you do and that's exactly what happened
what you said that's it those guys that
were slightly psychopathic yeah and then
it becomes okay I'm the on the head
psychopath and you're in my village and
you're let's say you're one of those
people that are in the middle well whose
side you're gonna be on I'm a psychopath
if you if you're not on my side I'm
gonna kill you next
yeah so you go huh no I'm on your side -
yeah and that's well it doesn't tailor
kits not like it takes much pressure
on people to have them fold I mean one
of the things you see you see happening
right now in our cultures that's
happening to people all the time with
these twitter wars you know someone will
say something they'll express an opinion
and then they'll get mobbed by and but
only abstractly right it's not like
there's pitchfork wielding mobs at their
house and I'm not making light of it
it's no it's no pleasant thing to be
mobbed on Twitter but that's that's an
abstraction compared to these people
showing up at your house you know and
yeah and what will happen is that people
will go through an abject apology you
know and they'll say well I really
didn't mean it and then now I understand
what my privilege is and I see how what
I said could have been very hurtful to
people and you know they they wander
through that entire apology and fold
almost instantly and and that's under
almost almost no pressure compared to
what real pressure is and real pressure
is when the Wolves are actually at your
door rather than just barking off in the
distance but people will fold just when
they're barking in the distance so
there's one lawyer that he talks about
in here is the same thing as the DES
story the new scribe I forget the guys
name but this guy was like the premier
prosecuting lawyer for the Soviet
government and he just rips people apart
over and over again and as you read
about what happens to him sure enough
he's one of the guys that that ended up
on the on the defensive and yeah being
executed yeah like yeah I see style they
built they built a place of butchery
and then threw themselves into it you
know that's and now and you see social
nets and documents this very carefully I
mean Stalin killed all the people who
who were foremost actors in the Russian
Revolution right so I mean everyone was
fed into the great grinding machine so
and and Stalin himself I mean it looked
to me like see he got himself into
something approximating a positive
feedback loop which is a very dangerous
thing to have happen and I think
Solzhenitsyn does a lovely job of
detailing this as well so it's like
imagine that I have a fair amount of
contempt for people to begin with and
then I find that
people are I'm not a trusting person and
I find that I'm very paranoid about the
fact that people are lying to me and
then I develop a certain amount of power
and a reputation well then people really
do start lying to me all the time in
every gesture you know because every
time they come near me they're
absolutely terrified and they're gonna
tell me anything that I want to hear and
of course then all that does is validate
my view of how pathetic and contemptible
everyone is and so and the more that
view gets validated the more I think
that it's okay to destroy people because
look at how pathetic and contemptible
they are how they always lie and all
that means is that they lie even more
and so this whole thing just spirals out
of control and you know Stalin basically
started out as a as the brutal
enforcement henchman for henchman for
Lenin right the the killer for hire and
not like Lenin was above that sort of
thing himself but but he trained Stalin
and and then Stalin's proclivity to be
murderous just kept expanding without
limit right first of all it was
individuals and then it was groups and
then it was nations and then well by the
end of his life well what was it the
plot to destroy the entire world to to
to to to initiate the third world war to
wipe out Europe to maybe destroy
everything and and like there's no limit
there was no limit to that you know and
there's some evidence that that's
perhaps why he was killed
you know because Stalin himself even
went too far for the horrible for the
horrible
what semi the corrupted compadres that
he had he'd arranged around himself he
went too far even for them and thank God
for that you know but yeah it's it's
it's absolutely I mean the thing that
that the Gulag Archipelago Gulag
Archipelago did for me and this was also
in keeping as a consequence also of
reading young at the same time but but
it was certainly the GU like in in large
part that did it I would say that in
some sense it scared me straight I
thought oh I see the the consequences of
unethical behavior deceit the
willingness to to turn a blind eye
so even sins of omission rather than
sins of commission just to turn a blind
eye the consequences of that are so
absolutely dreadful that it's not
acceptable and I think that's the right
lesson from the 20th century it's that
you you you you you have a much more
important moral role to play in keeping
things straight then you want to believe
you know people think well my life is
basically meaningless it's like well
that's quite terrifying it's like yeah
it's kind of terrifying but it means you
don't have any responsibility so there's
a big advantage to thinking that you
know now if nothing you do matters then
nothing you do matters and so you can do
whatever you want and and that's
horrifying Anna nihilistic sort of way
but there's another kind of horror
that's more associated I think with the
horror of hellfire that was
characteristic of the medieval christian
view is which is something like and if
you strip it of its metaphysics it's
something like no you don't get it the
things you do actually do the things you
do or don't do they actually do matter
and they tilt the world towards you know
something approximating good let's say
or towards something that very closely
approximates hell and that's actually on
you it's literally your fault it's
literally your responsibility it's like
man that's a terrifying I that's a
terrifying idea but I can't see how you
can read this literature without coming
to that conclusion like it wasn't one
that I wanted to leap to you know it's
like as it sits it's sort of the
ultimate in horrifying conclusions that
that everybody who participated in this
system was at fault for all of it in and
Dostoevsky made the same sorts of claims
in in in the last part of the 19th
century I mean he was a very weird
mystical sort of person you know and he
he made claims or some of his characters
did but on his behalf that you know not
only are you responsible for everything
you do but in some sense you're
responsible for everything that everyone
else does too and you think well
obviously there's a way in which that
isn't true
you know it's delusional in some sense
but there's another way in which it
actually is true you know and so well I
I wrote a book called extreme ownership
and it's it's very inner soul also all
this is a
whole thought here so you know when I
read the book about face which is not
about leadership it's not a leadership
book it's a it's a book about a guy that
was in the leadership position but he
doesn't say here's how you lead here's
what you do here it's a book about his
experience and what I took away from it
especially because I was in leadership
positions in in the military in combat
situations that I started seeing all
these leadership things that he did and
there's all this crossover because for
instance and so for me the crossover was
well I started learning about tactics
when I was a young kid because I was in
the military and the SEAL Teams and you
had to learn about how to fire and
maneuver like that's what you do and
then so you start learning about
leadership and then I started training a
lot of jujitsu and so those things kind
of all fit together and it's very
strange how those things started to
weave together in my head that oh if on
the battlefield if you want to attack
the enemy you don't do it head-on you
you flank them you distract them and
then you flank them you come in from the
other side in jujitsu if you want to
submit your opponent you you don't just
grab their arm no you start to choke
them and while they're defending the
choke then you get their arm and as a
leader if you want somebody to do
something you just don't bark that order
at them you flank them and you let them
understand why it's happening and and
you know when I started this podcast
that I do I I started off by saying in
the beginning I'd say that's a podcast
about leadership viewed through the lens
of war and atrocity and the more I did
it it didn't take me very long when I
was in waltz it's actually a podcast
about human nature really is what it's
actually about because the better you
understand human beings the better
you'll be able to do as a leader because
you'll understand what's happening with
those dynamics which I guess is now
leading me into some sort of psychology
of just kind of where you ended up with
of you read this book and you said you
were studying political science when you
read this book and then you said oh you
looked at the psychology of it and an
example that you just brought up and
this is just what you learn when you
read and when you understand history and
when you understand the way people think
stalin's surrounded himself with people
that would say yes to him
and anybody that didn't say yes to him
he killed them and I'll say this again
I'll talk to military she also killed
you if you said yes yeah the UH
I'll talk to military for sure but also
any business leader we talk to business
leaders all the time and you don't want
people you don't want your subordinates
or your superiors when you tell them
what to do to just nod their head and
say yes you don't want that now the the
the immediate fought especially for a
military guy they think they're nothing
would make my job easier then if I bark
an order at you Jordan you work from
you're a private and nama captain and I
bark an order you know you just shut up
and go do it and that seems like the
best thing in the world it's absolutely
not true because there's things that you
know on the front lines that I don't
know and if I really want to be a good
leader I want you to push back on me and
say hey boss we don't want to do that
here's what's going on let me tell you
the situation and instead of men you
want to be able to do that you want to
be able to teach your subordinates to do
that without being insubordinate right
because then it's not a power play it's
that your your interests are aligned our
interests are aligned and I actually
when I talk to the subordinates cuz I
talked to subordinates - yeah and I say
listen would you say something to your
boss you don't say why the hell are we
doing that because you actually have to
be very tacky yes yes exactly
hey hey hey boss um I want to make sure
I'm executing this exactly how you want
it can you explain to me why we're doing
this so I can really really make it
happen out there in the field you know
and that's a key thing so so these ideas
of you know psychology I guess now is I
hate to use that word but because I was
just calling a human nature but these
ideas they all kind of come together and
so now you're talking about ownership
right extreme ownership and this idea
that hey I'm responsible for everything
and and so here's what I'm getting from
a leader hmm they'll say well whether
it's a business leader or or it's it's
very easy to use a military leader so
I'll get a platoon commander my machine
gunner shot in the wrong direction how
can that be my fault mm-hm
because my machine gunner shot in the
wrong - I'm not I'm not holding his
weight and I'm not pulling his truck how
can that possibly be my fault that's not
my fault
wrong who's in charge of that machine
gun who's in charge of making sure he
what is fields of fire who's in charge
of making sure he understands when and
where he's allowed to shoot you are
you're the boss
this is absolutely your fault had it
another interesting example of the
weather the weather is bad we couldn't
execute our mission that's why we failed
because we couldn't launch our
helicopter yeah it's not my fault
yeah that's a hard one to argue against
yeah except for the fact that if you're
a good leader you'll say hey here's our
plan we're gonna use these helicopters
and here's our contingency yeah right if
there's bad weather you know if you
don't take that ownership of what's
going on if you don't take
responsibility for it you're not gonna
change it you're not gonna fix it and
that means you're never getting any
better you're not gonna win right but
the minute us end this and obviously
this applies to you know people to
purple in you and you know you tell
people to take responsibility I've you
know tell them take ownership but what's
going on in your world it's this it's
the same thing but at the end well it's
also it also seems to me to be the case
and I think that this is part of the
ethic that's embedded in in it's deeply
embedded in Christianity with the idea
that the idea that the ultimate
sacrifice that you can offer to the
world is the sacrifice of yourself it's
like well imagine that you have to
sacrifice something to set the world
right while you do obviously because you
have to give up things now in order to
make things better in the future so the
sacrificial idea is a very deep one then
the question might be well well if
you're gonna sacrifice something is it
going to be someone else or is it going
to be you and I really think that's the
fundamental question and the right
answer to that is that it's going to be
you it's your fault right you take that
on or at least you take on that
responsibility and it is it's a weird
thing weirdly difficult to distinguish
fault and responsibility I think
responsibility is the better way of
thinking about it but it's tied in with
the idea of fault if it doesn't go right
if it isn't going right it's because
you're not good enough now that can be
crushing there is a problem with that
like and you see sometimes people who
develop like psychotic depression and
they they they suffer from a delusional
condition in some sense that the entire
moral catastrophe of the world is
literally their fault and that's not
there there's an element of that that's
that's not productive
there's a truth in it as well you know
and and it's hard to it's hard to find
the balance so that you can take on that
responsibility without it simultaneously
being a crushing weight because there's
a lot of things in the world that are
really not good and if they're your
fault well that's rather hard on you
I mean one of the things that the
Catholic Church does to help people with
that is that it gives them the
opportunity to sort of wash their sins
off themselves right you can go to
church and you can say well look here's
a bunch of ways that I've been being not
who I could be and the church
authorities say well you know that's not
good and you should straighten up
and all of that and fly right but human
beings are fallible and you're fallible
and and and we can't just crush you
because of your insufficiency so we'll
wash the slate clean and you can go out
there and try again and and it's very
hard to get the balance between those
things right so that you can take the
responsibility on without being crushed
by it but but it's still the case that
it seems to me that it's either your
fault or it's someone else's and as soon
as it's someone else's then you better
be careful because that idea that it's
someone else's is definitely going to
appeal to the worst in you that's
definitely going to happen and if you
don't see that then you're naive or
willfully blind and and all that it's
gonna do all that's all that that is
going to do is make the situation worse
yeah especially because if it's not my
fault and it's your fault and I can't
control you what do I do about it I sit
there and it just suffer the
consequences of the situation as opposed
to okay here's what's going on I'm gonna
take responsibility and ownership for it
I'm gonna change it you make it happen
you talked about turning a blind eye and
earlier you talked about turning a blind
eye to the truth to a situation and I
know there's a point in this book where
he talks about the he's got a buddy that
says amnesty is coming right amnesty is
coming let's just keep our mouths shut
let's do what we're told to do and we'll
get you know we'll get out and coming
and you know Solzhenitsyn says
he's an okay yeah and then he says to
himself wait a minute if I'm not if I'm
not living in order to live then is it
worth it mmm-hmm and this is a question
that I get asked a lot because people
get themselves into situations where
they've lost some kind of control
whether it's they're in a crappy job or
they've got a bad boss yeah
or whatever maybe they're in a bad
relationship maybe their families met
but they're they're in a situation and
they and they don't know what to do and
part of them I think anticipates the
answer from me to be listen hey listen
if you're not if you're not living in
order to live than you that's wrong but
what I actually tell them universally
almost and there's a couple situations
where it goes outside this but you it's
like what I tell them is what you need
to do right now is you need to play the
game you need to play the game to get
the situation to a point where you can
act right so if you're you got a bad
boss right yeah oh you okay you got a
bye boss I want to tell this guy to go
screw himself yeah yeah hey guess what
I'm gonna do when my boss tells me
something to do that it doesn't make
much sense you know what I'm gonna do
I'm gonna do it and I'm gonna do it well
and what am i doing I'm building that
relationship with him he's starting to
trust me and he's gonna tell me up to do
something else now these things aren't
massive
Qatar's catastrophes it's like he's
telling me to do something maybe there's
a better way to do it you don't know how
to do it that way mmm-hmm and I'm gonna
play that game and I'm gonna build up
that relationship now when eventually he
tells me to do something that is totally
stupid or it's gonna cost you no lives
or money then when I say hey boss that's
not a great way to do it I think I know
a better way couldn't we try something
else he actually will listen to me so
I'm gonna play the game a little bit and
I'll tell you my gut instinct if now I
guess it's it's easy to look from the
outside and say hey if I was in this
prison camp my gut instinct is like okay
Jacque would you know you've been
through these kind of things before play
the game you're gonna play the game
which is horrifying mm-hmm because part
of playing that game to the fullest
extent here or in a Nazi prison camp
would become in a capital yeah oh you're
playing the game yeah yeah you're
playing the game yeah so and that's
really the outlying that the things that
I said that are outlying I always make
the caveat that if you're getting asked
to do something that's immoral illegal
or unethical then you actually have a
duty to say no I'm not gonna do that
no that's the that's the line which you
know which you reach that line in the
sand with Bill c16 but which is hey I'm
not going to do this but the idea that
sometimes you got to play the game and
yeah well that's even from you when you
just said to me you said well you know
sometimes you it's not right to turn a
blind eye on things and it's like
sometimes you have to if you want to get
yourself to a position like my well it
seems to me that you're making a
distinction between discipline and
strategy like and and and and like
impulsive moral responding you know like
let's say that you are in a situation
where you have a boss who's intolerable
and maybe what you'd like to do you know
the resentment has built up over five
years and you'd like to go in there and
and yell at them and tell them
everything you think and you think well
that's the truth it's like well it's
actually it's not a very sophisticated
truth because you're doing as shallow
and the impulsive analysis of this
situation like it would have been the
case that you've already compromised
yourself in 500 ways and I'll get back
to the playing the game issue because
you do have to discipline yourself to
and and you have to discipline yourself
to some degree by allowing yourself to
do arbitrary things that are part of the
system right that's necessary part of
discipline and discriminating that from
compliance with unethical activity is
very difficult so that's a hard
situation but let's say you're you're
you're going to counsel someone who has
an intolerable boss and they come in and
they're right at the end of their tether
because maybe that's why they come for
counseling they say I really want to
tell that son of a [__] what I think of
him and you think well wait a second
here okay first of all you've already
eradicated
from the list of reasonable
possibilities that decision by failing
to say small things that you could have
said all the way along and it's not like
you can just all of a sudden blurt all
of that out now and that wipes the slate
clean and that constitutes truth it's
too unsophisticated so let's think okay
so what is it that you want well I don't
want this job anymore
it's like okay now let's actually have a
strategy about this then you don't want
this job anymore can you get another job
well I don't think so well so you can't
just quit well no I can't because then I
don't have any money and my family
depends on the job it's like okay so you
can't just stop this that that's not a
viable solution you go out of the frying
pan into the fire or you know you suck
you you substitute one set of unethical
actions for another set of unethical
actions that are even worse that's not
helpful
all right so let's start thinking about
what exactly it is that you want it's
like well maybe I want a better job I
want to work for someone who's more
reasonable ok so what's stopping you
well I don't have my CV in order my
resume isn't up to date well why is that
well I haven't done it for five years
and I don't like doing it well why is
that well because I'm kind of
embarrassed about it because it has
holes in it then it shows where I'm
lackadaisical and where I'm not prepared
it's like ok how many things are there
like that well there's a bunch of things
and they're all associated with how I
procrastinated in the past it's like ok
what are we going to do to rectify that
so I'll say to people why don't you
update your CV that's what we'll do
first because if you're going to look
for a different job I'm not saying
you're gonna look for a different job
but if you're going to look for a
different job you're not going to unless
your CV s updated one is not going to
unless you can get a good recommendation
from this boss that's a Terran and so
that's right there's you gotta play
there's Tanis strategic actions that
you're gonna have to take in order to
make yourself able to move laterally or
up and the truth is isn't going in and
yelling at your boss and telling them
everything you think about them the
truth is trying to figure out the very
very difficult process of how you put
yourself in a better position and that
out like one of the things that's quite
fun about this lecture tour
is the letters that I receive or the
stories that people tell me about
switching jobs because they do realize
that there and I often talk to people
about consulting their resentment
resentments are really useful emotion
like it's really dangerous it's one of
the most dangerous psychological states
I believe but it's unbelievably useful
because resentment usually only means
one of two things it either means quit
whining and and take it on because
you're immature or it means you're
allowing yourself to be taken advantage
of and you have something to say or do
and so you want to sort out the first
part and find out if you're just being
immature and you can think that through
and you can talk to people and but in
that but if it's the second it's like no
you've compromised yourself in a variety
of ways and you have to figure out how
to get out of that and if you're
resentful that's evidence that you have
in fact done that okay so now that issue
would be well how can you set your life
up so that you can be without that
resentment and so that's when you start
to develop a strategy for you know and
and it there's actually an adventure in
this tool I mean I've had a number of
clients who have been in jobs that they
didn't like at all and you know they
were terrorized by someone for example
and they were also working below their
hypothetical level and we'd put together
a plan it's like okay you're gonna make
three times as much money in in five
years that's the plan but like that's
not gonna be simple so you there's
education you got to educate yourself
maybe formally because you've got holes
you got to fix up your resume you've got
to you've got to overcome your fear of
being interviewed you have to start
sending out like 50 resumes a week on a
regular basis and be prepared for a 99%
rejection rate you you're going to look
for a different job it's probably going
to take six months to a year and almost
all of that is going to be rejection you
got to steal yourself from for that and
prepare and maybe this is going to be a
three year process it's no trivial thing
but you know it's almost inevitably I
can't remember a single example where
the consequence of that very careful
detailed strategic thinking wasn't
massively substantive improvement in
socio-economic positioning
and a great movement towards a an
improving trajectory and and and there's
advantages even along the way because
even before that happens the fact that
you're taking genuine steps to put
yourself in a better situation
immediately starts to reduce your
resentment even if it isn't having
positive consequences to begin with but
you have to be realistic about it's like
look it's gonna be hard to update your
CV because you're embarrassed about it
and you should be alright it's no wonder
you're embarrassed about it and then
well of course you don't want to go be
interviewed because you're not very good
at it and there's holes in your story
and and your and you can be made nervous
easily and you're not a very good
advocate for yourself so there's a lot
of improvement that needs to be done
there and and then you have to withstand
the the the punishment of being
constantly rejected when you apply for
jobs because the baseline rejection rate
you know for the for the typical job
applicant is like 99 percent it's like
the rejection rate for everything is
this gonna work no but if you do it a
hundred times
it might work once that's all you need
that's exactly it you you you only need
that once and so the truth there isn't
to yell at your boss the truth there is
to get your life together yeah play the
game you gotta play the game sometimes
to to get a strategic win to me and
that's and another interesting thing
here is as I say you don't want to
surround yourself with yes-men when
you're a leadership position you also
don't want to be your own personal
yes-man that just thinks you're great
and agrees with everything that you're
doing and and won't tell yourself the
hard truth you know you can't lie to
yourself everything every little one of
those things that you just listed off
are the kind of things that people just
lie to themselves and say yeah you know
what well you don't really need that
that person didn't learn anything and
that in that course why should I go to
it that you know it's like if you don't
tell yourself the truth about your what
your situation is it's gonna be
problematic just like if you don't have
people on your team above you or below
you in the chain of command that tell
you the truth that's gonna be
problematic as well which is something
here which is something that's easier
so the playing the game thing so are you
thinking about that as a consequence of
necessary discipline you know like
because they're weak because it seems to
be you're making two cases at the same
time right one is that you should
obviously not undertake unethical
actions but then by the same token and
and you have to subordinate yourself to
the realities of the situation and and I
think that that's psychologically true
because you're always in a situation
where if you're in an organization
there's kind of an arbitrary and
tyrannical aspect to it because it's
never working perfectly and then and
then there's the the positive aspect to
it too and so whenever you're doing a
job it could be that you're you're
called upon to do things that what would
you say that are a necessary part of the
operation of the machinery I guess that
would be particularly true in military
situation yes and let me give you well
just a broad example right you know my
personality and my reputation is that
you know when I was in the military it's
like oh it's Jocko hey he's not gonna
you know he's if someone tells him to do
something doesn't want to do he's just
gonna you know say screw you yeah we're
not doing we're doing it my way you know
um I got the nut butt and that was kind
of the impression people would get from
me if they didn't know me from the
outside they think oh this guy's a
knuckle dragger he's gonna go forward
he's gonna make things happen and he's
not gonna listen anyone else that was
the impression from the outside the
reality is a you you can't do that and
and be the reality is what my actions
right I'd have you know a young
lieutenant would come to me and say hey
you know my bosses do tell me to do this
this and this and what they think I was
gonna say is like bro you don't do that
right end up you tell him screw you that
doesn't make any sense and maybe they
get this look in their eyes of surprise
yeah when I'd say oh your boss wants you
to do that do it do it well play the
game that's what I'm telling to do is
play the game because these things are
meaningless it's something you know is
something is patheticness like oh you
got to fill out a form a certain way
it's like hey shut up and play the game
look even Maya so is that a Madol matter
of picking your battles it certainly is
a matter of picking your battles and you
as that's part of strategy right like
everything can't be the war a
exactly and it's exactly what it is but
you know a good example and we wrote
about it in in dichotomy leadership
which is you know my friend my guy that
worked for me Lafe babban we were
getting told to do all this paperwork
you gotta you gotta fill out these forms
you've gotta you gotta have a serialized
inventory of everything it's gotta be
signed off this many days we need to
know the the qualifications of each and
every person and when their
qualifications come up due and all these
just ridiculous paperwork and Lafe came
to me and with with the other platoon
commander guy named Seth that came to me
and said ah man this is [__] why do
we got to do all this paperwork we're
we're here training for war we're
getting ready for war why we got to do
this and you know life will tell you his
and expectation was that I was gonna be
like you're right I'm gonna go to the
commanding officer and tell him screw
this we're not doing this stuff this is
crap we're trying to prepare because we
were in training getting ready to deploy
to Iraq this is crap we're not doing
this and I looked at him and said oh
we're doing all of this paperwork and
not only were you gonna do this
paperwork we're gonna do it better than
anyone else and we're gonna turn it in
before it's even do you know we both him
and Seth were kind of taken aback then
the fact that I wasn't standing up and
saying we're not doing this crap and
then I explained him here's what we're
doing we're building a relationship with
my commanding officer with our
commanding officer we're gonna do these
little things for him we're gonna play
the game because at some point two
things are gonna happen number one we
want to build trust with my boss I want
my boss to look at me and when he tells
me to do to fill out paperwork he knows
gonna be filled out if he wants me to
take down a building he knows it's gonna
get taken out if he wants me to execute
up a larger mission I'll go and get it
done we're built if I can't fill out
paperwork correctly how can you trust me
to go on and on a real operation and
have guys lives at risk so the idea is
like hey we're gonna play the game and I
think sometimes people start to hear me
they start to listen to me and their
first instinct is Jaco wouldn't put up
with them [__] yeah and that's why these
you know they'll hit me up the same
thing they'll write me an email they'll
write me a letter and say here's the
situation I'm in on whether it's a boss
whether it's a military it's any of them
whether it's their wife like like my
wife
it's me not to change it to something as
stupid as that like my wife won't let me
train it's driving me crazy it's really
starting to bother me but why won't she
well what's the problem hey have you
taken her out for dinner you mean like
play the damn game a little bit so that
you can win strategically and it's the
same thing I think with your with the 12
rules we were like hey tell the truth or
at least don't lie it's like I get it
but there's a dichotomy in that
statement and that is if you run around
telling the absolute truth that everyone
it's gonna be like that Jim Carrey movie
where he can't say anything that's not
100% true and you know Gert woman says
good morning and he says you look fat
you know it's like one of those like
very not good and so you gotta learn to
play the game and and I guess again
going back to this book it's like that's
a tough call to make in these situations
how much do you play the game and
there's an ethical line that you could
cross at some point if I become a capo
Hey hmm you just you played the game and
you went too far with it and just like
in a leadership situation if Ike if
you're my boss and I'm just kissing your
ass and do wonder every to my guys lose
respect for me yeah my team will lose
respect for me if you tell me to do
something completely stupid and I say
hey guys that's what the boss says we're
doing it my guys will lose respect for
me and I won't be I won't be able to
execute missions the way I should if
when the pushback is proper I say hey
hey boss yeah that doesn't make any
sense we shouldn't do that and I go to
the guys and say listen I told I talked
to him we're gonna see what he says but
trust me if we have to do this we'll
we'll figure out a way to make it work
because if you're just the guy that's
totally on board if you're a brown-noser
right you're Pete your guys will lose
respect for you 100% they will they'll
lose respect for you if you don't play
the game at all and you push back on
everything that your boss says you're
gonna you're not gonna get fired
yeah that's another DEATH achill
situation like if my mom if you're my
boss and you tell me to do something
that's I don't believe in or it's like a
bad plan and I may I draw the line in
the sand and say screw you Jordan we're
not doing it you can fire me you're like
okay fine you fire me you get some
yes-man to come in he takes my guys out
on the mission and get some all killed
he didn't mitigate the risk properly it
better for me ethically to say hey look
Jordan I don't agree with this plan I
really wish we could do it another way
is there any way I could flex on it you
say nope you're doing it this way it is
better for me in many situations to say
okay oh I got it
an indication of the complexity of the
truth I mean one of the rules of thumb
that I think is worth abiding by and I
guess this is something that makes me
somewhat conservative in some ways is
that you should do what everyone else
does unless there's a very good reason
not to and and I think that's I think
that's the same idea that you're putting
forward which is that if you if you do
fight back against everything then
you're just too rebel without a cause
right and you and you discredit yourself
entirely and if you accept everything
well then you're not even there and so
there's some judicious analysis of the
situation that helps you understand when
the time for action is right and most of
the time what you're doing in life is
you're doing what other people do and
that's going along with the game that's
part of being socialized but there's
going to be times when the right thing
to do is to break a rule and to do it
very carefully and so and there's a
there's a there's a there's a scene I
think this is a New Testament scene but
it might be in some of the apocryphal
right apocryphal writings I don't
remember so Christ is walking down the
road on the Sabbath and there's there's
a ditch by the road and it's very hot
and in the ditch there's a hole and in
the hole there's a sheep and so the
Sheep is stuck in the hole and this guy
Shepherd is trying to get the Sheep out
of the hole and Christ walks by and he
says if you don't understand what you're
doing you're a transgressor of the law
and you're cursed but if you do
understand what you're doing then you're
blessed so it's it's it's a perfect
example of that a because it's it's like
if you're okay now here's your situation
you're a shepherd and you're supposed to
be taking care of that sheep right but
it's the Sabbath day so you're not
supposed to be working now if you have
decided you've thought this through you
think it's the Sabbath day this is
something that everybody needs because
everybody needs to take a rest and this
is a rule I shouldn't break because
everybody needs to take a rest or things
degenerate and I understand
and I have a lot of respect for it but I
think that in this situation it's still
morally appropriate for me to break that
rule in this slight way and get this
poor sheep out of this hole
then while Christ's judgment was well
then you're exactly on the right track
but if you're doing it carelessly and
stupidly you're breaking that rule then
you're a transgressor of the law and
you're cursed and I think that's exactly
at the essence of what you're describing
it's like you play by the rules but then
there's a meta rule which is now and
then you break the rules and you do that
very very carefully because when you
break the rules you're breaking the
rules and the rules are what keep peace
they're what keep peace and order and so
you break them only in the service of a
higher peace and order and so that seems
to be and I think that's you see this in
in well the sorts of stories that are
influencing even the things that you're
writing like in the Harry Potter series
for example Harry's friends and campaig
treats are quite disciplined Hermione in
particular because she's an absolute
master of her craft but they still break
rules when it's necessary only when it's
necessary and that's what makes them
more than the people who are just
breaking rules all the time the villains
so to speak and also makes them more
than the people that are just being good
by being conformist so you need that
that touch of rebellious nut
it's got to be a flavoring and not the
whole diet absolutely I've actually
talked about that on this podcast before
the there's people in the military that
they are like meta rule-followers these
are people that have been following
rules or whole lives yeah they've got
perfect grades and they were the team
can do all these things and they're
gonna make really good solid leaders
like they're gonna be great leaders yep
but then there's this like one group
above them yeah have that same thing but
they also have that little bit of
rebellion that they'll say you know what
we're not doing that it doesn't make any
sense
and that is really an important factor
to have yeah but you know that's one of
the reasons I like this guy Colonel
david hackworth
this guy was the ultimate rule follower
for his whole career at the end
in Vietnam he did an interview and said
if we keep fighting this way we're not
gonna win this war mm-hmm and they drove
him out of the army mhm but that's
that's the thing that because all along
the way there was other times where he
do that you know his guys weren't
getting taken care of he'd break a rule
and bring him beer or he do you know
yeah he'd do that along the way not not
so far outside the bounds that it would
jeopardize his career because if he
would do that then you're not in charge
of these guys anymore yeah now you're
not gonna have any impact yeah so let's
not get fired right right let's not get
stupidly fired right that's not an
improvement exactly well that's a
awesome
I guess we I know you got to go so I
can't think that we could get to a
better little crust of the little
capstone of the conversation than right
there thanks for coming on again hey my
pleasure man I'm glad we got a chance to
talk about this book this is a book that
everybody should read and and you you I
ordered the I ordered a copy of yours
with a Ford yet from Europe yep you
can't buy it from Amazon here you know
yet from Amazon so it'll be here when
will it but I don't know we're still
negotiating the rights cuz the rights
holders differ in North America and so
that's the issue at the moment sofa so I
worked with an English publisher penguin
in in the UK that that put out the I
think it's Vantage books if I remember
correctly I should just check and make
sure that that's exactly right
Harper Perennial modern classics that is
not that's not the British one oh that's
no that's not the British one hasn't
gotten to my house yeah I'm so [__] yeah
it has to be ordered it has to be
ordered through Amazon UK and we're
working on a couple of things maybe two
also maybe get the audio rights to the
abridged version because I'd like to
read it nice and that would be good so
that people could listen to it and so
because it's it's an absolutely
necessary book yeah and it's written
actually what I like because it's
written very conversation I mean he's
cracking jokes in there and he's making
it's a brilliant piece of literature as
well as I mean it's a very readable book
although it's unbelievably harsh and and
and demanding and and draining to read
but it's it's brilliantly written it's
an unbelievably engrossing read and in
the most horrible possible way but and
and it is the case
it's written at this white-hot pace you
know it's like talking to someone who's
righteously not self righteously angry
but righteously angry four four ball
four four four dozens of hours and you
just can't believe the levels of outrage
that are that are being that are being
so incredibly well expressed and so
effectively expressed and and and again
I think it's also worth emphasizing the
fact that you know Solzhenitsyn's real
contribution in many ways was to lay the
catastrophe at the feet of the doctrine
and not to say no this is this wasn't an
aberration because of Stalin or you know
Lenin being the great leader and then
Stellan being the monster because Lenin
was plenty monster himself and Stalin
was the logical conclusion to Lenin not
not an aberration but to say that no the
horrors of what happened in the Soviet
Union were were implicit in the
collectivist system utopian system that
gave rise to the philosophy to begin
with and that that's also an explanation
why the same catastrophes occurred
wherever the Soviet system was applied
everywhere else in the world it's
something we really need to know I mean
we fought a whole Cold War over that we
put damn near put the world to the torch
because of this and the idea that these
ideas are the fact that these ideas are
creeping back is really it's unbearable
as far as I'm concerned so hopefully
people read in this book and the the
re-release of this book with your ford
will prevent that from happening in the
other people can put drops into as well
and so i'm hoping i mean i think the
book has sold 15,000 copies since the
beginning of november which is pretty
good for the reissue an old classic but
like it it it's required reading for an
informed citizen of the 21st century
it's not optional you need to know this
material you're not you're not you don't
understand your position in society as
an individual or a citizen without
knowing this material so it's like not
knowing about what happened in Nazi
Germany it's not acceptable to not know
read the book thanks for coming good
really good see again man
absolutely yeah be better appreciate it
and with that Jordan Pederson has
departed the recording studio and if you
noticed that echo Charles was not
present during the recording with Jordan
Peterson but through the miracle of
technology and recording echo has now
joined us for the support Neil portion
of this podcast so good evening echo
good evening alright so if people listen
to this podcast which we appreciate
and you want to support this podcast and
support yourself there are ways to do
that echo can fill you it sure so first
way is when you're doing jiu-jitsu
because we're all doing jiu-jitsu yes it
might sound a little bit repetitive but
to me when you do just gonna be doing it
every single day every single week at
least even if you're doing the two times
a week treat I get it either way you're
gonna need a key and a rash guard so
there is no question which kind of gear
you get you get an orange in game
straight up made in America I watched
one of their videos yesterday and it's
kind of a older one too but it made me
like love origins even more because it's
like you'll see you know the people that
make them and all the ladies there and
then Pete like he has like longer hair
and stuff like that as I called man
that's kind of one of the beginnings of
origin you know anyway I thought it was
good unless again made in America
quality stuff for jiu-jitsu it's not
like a blankie they get from over
wherever some other place and then slap
a embroidered patch on it no say that no
this is made for jiu-jitsu in America
yeah everything made in America from
where where we grow the materialist
grown in America woven in America woven
in Maine as a matter of fact custom
woven by origin
we weave it up there and make the best
keys in the world also got some other
stuff for you know you got t-shirts you
can get sweatshirts and also coming in
2019 jeans yeah
denim origin denim yeah I just call them
jeans though yeah yeah I dig yet that
starts to like I don't know move towards
a fashion thing what if you see dent in
denim well I feel oh yeah I guess I'll
just steal that material yeah I feel
like it's like origin denim they make it
you know yeah and then yeah they make
origin jeans for sure but what if they
make like a jean jacket like a denim
jacket no I'd be true but it'll be a
jean jacket that's true yeah I dig it
cool either way yeah that's - and I
don't get excited for jeans in general
in life
oh no yeah like you know you see it on
TV I don't know
JCPenney has a sale you know black fryer
whatever and you know some jeans I don't
get excited do you prime assuming you
don't either maybe do I don't know but
when people's little like videos of the
clothes you know close-up of the buttons
the jeans come on grab that's that's
kinda exciting I'm just saying
either way yeah either way the also we
have supplements to affirmative origin
labs which is expanding yes Lee yeah
yeah we bought another building up there
but yes so they're making we are making
supplements joint warfare krill oil
super krill oil by the way discipline
mmm the try effect oh yeah yeah the my
wife went on the trip didn't take join
warfare with her yeah she's there for
3-4 days her knee starts bothering her
it bothers her the rest of the trip she
comes home she goes back on joint
warfare for 3-4 days
nice fight again yeah see let me that's
just that's a scream yeah
that's just a reality of it so join
warfare good for your joints krill oil
also good for your joints and good for
your good for your whole life system is
that a thing life system life yes okay
well yeah it's good for that too
discipline when you need that focus and
also discipline go yeah which is my
three cognitive enhancement tool go to
go to here yeah yeah yeah the it's funny
the krill I had the same situation too
by the way oil and joint Warford didn't
bring it yeah
by the way in Hawaii which is the reason
why I didn't appear on this episode of
the podcast you know why so my
father-in-law came I told him the story
about how he'd always talk about krill
oil and he's just sort of looking at me
like whatever and um you know he used to
tell me oh yeah krill oil is good good
for you all this stuff and he said not
listen cuz you know he's more of like
little health dude and then when you
started talking about it like literally
the day you start talking I start taking
it and he was like he didn't care it
kind of went right over his head and I
was like oh so did you feel the
difference you know like that's what he
was concerned about also on top of that
you got Moke which is which is mulk
basically that's what it is it's a it
has protein in it you mix it with milk I
got a man I to make that statement if
you mix it with well you can mix it with
almond milk you can mix it with coconut
milk you can mix it with regular cow
milk if you mix it with water it's not
I'm not jumping up and down about it and
telling you it's the most delicious
thing in the world if you mix it with
milk whole milk especially I will tell
you it's it's a it's a dessert
straight-up it's a dessert that you will
make you stronger if so you know like
hot cocoa you ever make oh yeah okay so
I'm a fan that you can put in water
right what do you put in water in milk
mmm that is not hot cocoa to me okay I
know what you're talking about you eat
the little the little packet that you're
supposed to mix with water it's got the
little crappy marshmallows in it yeah
that's not this a non-starter for me
yeah so that's kind of the point there
yeah it's sorta that you know along the
same lines where it said cool do it and
it's okay you can do it yep and in
there's probably many many many people
who do that and I'm not mad at them but
you put the milk that stuff is my thing
and by the way you can't have you can't
have hot chocolate milk yeah
it's er it's right up there special work
Edelen yeah the sir got mint chocolate
peanut butter chocolate vanilla gorilla
and the darkness and then there's the
the warrior kid milk which has a little
bit less protein in it unless you double
up on your scoops like I do for the
strawberry because the strawberry is
ridiculously good so give that a shot
and by the way all these things are
available at origin main calm and that's
that's the state of Maine yeah yeah
not just Maine like the main spot even
though it is the main spot check cool so
yeah also if you want to represent you
know get a discipline equals freedom
shirt or a rash guard you know get after
it any way you want to represent the
path go to Jacko's store.com that's
where you can get all this stuff hoodies
you know hey christmas is coming up
let's face it there's no avoiding it
it's coming up you know so you want to
grab something that's a good place to
grab something some new stuff on there
too but yeah if you're gonna represent
while on the path jaw closed or calm
good stuff also Chaka white tea so these
claims of deadlifting 8,000 pounds I
haven't dead lifted in a while so I was
like you know what I'm gonna dump in a
test it cans right and he drink it
straight up deadly deadlift at 8,000
pounds just like that just like that no
warmup even know you don't need it you
know it's really the warm-up is drinking
some chocolate yeah when you're warmed
up and you're good 8000 pound deadlift
yeah that's you know this is the only
product in the world in any capacity
that guarantees 100% 8000 pound deadlift
minimum yeah but yeah so yeah you get
them one in the dry eBags
if that's your thing when you see Paul C
that's the word yeah yeah he's deep
Steve okay boom if you like that gig huh
hot cold whatever and then the cans
which I recommend I recommend they can
actually I don't know if I'd recommend
it but I prefer they I like them both
yeah depending on the scenario Emira
boom there you go also subscribe to the
podcast on iTunes and stitcher and
Google Play wherever you listen to
podcast there's a lot of new ones out
there there's no apps yeah and there's a
lot of podcasts out there yeah and
listen to a bunch of them yeah yeah and
one of them you can also listen to in
addition to this one if you want you can
check out the warrior kid podcast that's
basically directed at kids but I'll tell
you that uncle Jake has lessons for
everyone in that podcast and also we got
the YouTube channel the YouTube channel
where you can watch this podcast in its
full length and you can see what people
look like if you don't know what Jordan
B Peterson looks like if you don't know
what Eko Charles look like or if you
don't know what I look like you can
watch the YouTube channel and you can
see all of us if you never heard if
you've never seen echo before but you've
only heard him he probably doesn't look
like what you think he looks like yeah
and I don't know if that's good or bad
enough that's a backhanded compliment or
a backhanded like derogatory statement
about you yeah your voice yeah a little
bit of both yeah but but will will
suffice it to say that he's not what you
expect when you see him in reality and
he also makes videos that are enhanced
by imagery and music yeah and those are
on there too so you can check those out
you can subscribe to that YouTube
channel also we got the psychological
warfare album and that has tracks on it
of well they're of me telling you
pragmatically why you should or should
not do something like skip a workout you
should not skip a workout eat donuts you
should not eat donuts so just some
little things like that you can check
that out psychological warfare echo
claims that it has 100% effectiveness
yeah it does should you go to the gym
yes you should and if you listen to the
track you will go to the gym yes 100%
effective and actually I mean a lot of
claims being made about effectiveness on
this yes an Arial right now hey it's if
it's real it's real you know this mmm
double-blind placebo tested yeah well
you know single-blind maybe
okay no that means but and it is
official when okay and I kind of tried
to psychologically and I'll analyze
psychological warfare like why does it
work every single time and here's part
of it even you you know like when you
get hypnotized I'm not saying you're we
should have I should have asked I should
have asked Jordan this question yes and
you'd agree with this I think okay I
think that goes bro fear so you know
like being hypnotized for example yeah
you I've never been hypnotized yeah me
neither so what but then again it's real
what happens - so have you ever said a
volunteer did not get that okay me
neither same thing so hypnotism from
what I understand is you have to like be
what he call like successful open to it
yeah open to it yeah so if you're a
suggestible person that's like you have
a certain kind of mind and then on top
of that even more consciously you have
to volunteer to be hypnotized a guy I
mean I'm sure there's methods that you
can sort of hypnotize someone without
them knowing it or something but usually
even say I'm sure but oh yeah that's
right you can even there's Owen and then
or not nonetheless usually the hypnotic
sequence goes through hey you volunteer
like consciously yeah sure I'll be
hypnotizing you sit there and you're up
to ten and you're closing your eyes and
breathing anyway so you consciously
volunteered to be hypnotized so you're
open to being hypnotized and then blah
blah blah so psychological warfare it's
like hey you recognize okay I have this
weakness I'm about to skip this workout
right now you're basically saying hey I
need a help I need nothing you know I
need a little spark volunteering for
help well in Tyrian yeah it's not like
I'm like sitting in my rooms not
completely against your will exactly
right you're not just busting in the
door you know insane hey don't skip the
workout meanwhile in your mind you
already committed to keeping the way
it's different so you're like you're not
committed to keeping the work out you
just like are running the risk of
skipping the work you know that weakness
just creeps in and you're like hey I see
you weakness you're creeping in right
now I'm gonna get I'm basically I'm
gonna tell Jocko that you're in here and
he's gonna you know make you leave and
you play the track
whatever you have it on your phone right
because you had you have all your
playlists on your phone anyway you just
play the psychological warfare one and
you but you won't skip to work out soon
saying because you don't want to skip
the workout in there no one wants to
skip the work on no one's thinking
tomorrow I can't wait to skip this
workout it's not like that you know so
it's you come in and you just give that
little nudge that's why it works so good
it's true absolutely true I like it
psychological it's very effective
hundred-percent also while you're
working out and if you're bored with
your squats bench get some kettlebells
from on it in my opinion on it calm /jo
good stuff on there
jump rope battle ropes kettlebells clubs
may be careful with the clubs mmm Kasia
I was watching a video of a guy doing
this Club routine I was like dang heat
it took a lot of coordination like I'm
looking at it and I was like 40 I think
like a big one yeah I can't even imagine
trying to do anything coordinated yeah
with the 40 yes cuz I only have 220 yeah
and yes and they come off real a lot
more heavy than they look oh yeah like
when you grab them at the end of the day
if it's 20 pounds 20 pounds no there's
no getting past that physically but when
you pick it up it's like it's like you
know when you pick up your friend yeah
you know or your kid freaking and they
weight 70 pounds it's like Shh I pick up
70 pounds with one hand it's no problem
when it's a dumbbell try pick up your
kid when there's 70 bucks with one hand
can't do it it's hard unless that's all
these clubs are anyway so watch out for
those anyway go to on it calm flash drop
they can get some really cool stuff on
there really cool awesome a we got some
books as well first off miking the
dragons I know Jordan and I talked about
it a little bit today and it was
actually sold out for a little bit it is
now back in stock and have many many
many thousands and thousands of copies
that are inbound that are being printed
so if you want Mikey and the Dragons go
to Amazon and order it there's a little
video on there if you want to know what
it's about
go put together and it's a it's a solid
video from what I understand the like
kids like to watch the video oh you like
it's like a little mini short it's super
fast is two minutes even in even my kids
so we're in I watched the video if you
are send it to me I watched it like 14
times elements in it a lot of things
going on yeah to my son it's like a
micro cartoon kinda no it's like a micro
movie yeah I don't know why well it's a
cartoon because there's the illustration
illustration yeah but yeah it's fun we
put on the TV when I was in Hawaii you
know you have a smart TV and there you
can put YouTube on there oh you thought
I put on the TV and my kids are all
jumping over them like in this you know
it's two minutes long
yeah no I you know Jordan and I were
talking about it and you know obviously
it's about facing your dragons and
there's obviously a metaphor there and
it's a there's real true pragmatic
simple to understand lessons of how to
stand up and confront the world and
confront your fears that little kids
will clearly and easily understand and
it'll leave an impact on anybody that
reads it so miking the dragons you can
get that book on top of that if you got
kids you can also get them the way of
the warrior kid which is another book
about a young kid who's going through
the problems that normal kids have and
luckily his uncle Jake who was a seal
and the SEAL Teams shows up for the
summer and helps him overcome those
problems and then that series carries on
another book called Mark's mission you
can pick those two books up and give me
day whatever kids you those look those
books when you read those books you'll
wish you had that book when you were kid
I know I absolutely wish I had that book
when I was a kid and I wish I had that
book when my kids were kids yeah because
it teaches them what it is they need to
know period that's it the discipline
equals freedom Field Manual that book
that's how you do that's how you is it's
just a field manual of how to be on the
path of discipline that's what it is
look the path of discipline is not easy
and there's no Field Manual for it oh
wait there is now but there didn't used
to be there didn't you speak look I know
someone will help me how do I get
discipline where does discipline come
from this none of that information was
assembled anywhere hmm
I made a field manual for it it's called
the discipline equals freedom Field
Manual it's not it's it's not like any
other book you've ever seen or read
period it's not but it's very popular
it's great if you want there's another
thing Creek christmas is coming this is
a Christmas scenario right this is a
Christmas scenario give this book to
somebody that needs help or needs to
stay on the path or get on the path this
book will be extremely beneficial to
them or people that are on the path
getting after it this will keep them
there so that's the Field Manual if you
want the audio version that it is not
inaudible it's on iTunes and Amazon
music and Google Play as an mp3 also the
first book I wrote with my brother Leif
babban it's called extreme ownership but
that is a book taking the leadership
lessons that we learned on the
battlefield and translating them to your
business and to your life and then the
follow up to that book is the dichotomy
of leadership which takes those lessons
that we learned in combat and goes
granular in teaching you how to balance
the various dichotomies that you
experience as a leader so both and all
those books are available on Amazon or
wherever else you might to buy books
also we got a salon front which is uh my
leadership consultancy we solve problems
through leadership that's what we do and
we work with companies all over the
country and internationally if you want
us to come and align the leadership at
your company for victory then go to a
salon front calm the we are do we have a
Leadership Conference called the muster
and we've done six musters we are doing
three in 2019 we're doing one in Chicago
in the spring we're doing one in Denver
in the fall and we're doing Sydney
Australia in December so if you want to
come to one of those events all the
events that we've done have sold out all
of them these are all absolutely going
to so sell out so if you want to come go
to extreme ownership calm
and register and as quick as you can and
then lastly we have EF overwatch we are
connecting Special Operations veterans
and combat aviation veterans that are
looking for work that are proven leaders
that are experienced leaders and we're
connecting them with companies out there
in the civilian sector that need leaders
so if you want to come at that from
either side whether you're a vet or
whether you're a company go to EF
overwatch comm to get in the game and if
you have any more questions for us or
answers for us we are available on the
interwebs on Twitter and on Instagram
and on the face book e echo is adequate
Charles and I am at Jocko willing and I
started out this podcast today pretty
heavy pretty rough and I think it's
important to remember something that I
always refer back to and that is that
evil does exist in the world it's out
there and with that I'd like to thank
all the military personnel throughout
the globe that stand up to evil in the
world and thanks to police and law
enforcement and firefighters and
paramedics and EMTs and correctional
officers and Border Patrol and all the
first responders that stand up and face
evil here at home and to everyone else
out there if things are tough and I know
they get tough life is hard but there's
still reason to be thankful be thankful
you're not in a gulag be thankful that
you're not being tortured be thankful
that you have food to eat be thankful
you have a bed to sleep on and then do
your best to watch out for those little
seeds of evil that are planted around
you and plant it in you and keep
those seeds of evil in check by going
out into the world and doing good and
until next time this is echo and Jocko